there's the issue with the Red Sox and
the Yankees going on right now Peter
Gammons of the MLB Network joining us
here in the Rich Eisen show right now
how are you Peter I really like your you
said you got sidetracked it was really
good I was listening so I presume that
it's I couldn't agree more
I believe it's the same thing for me for
45 to 46 years covering baseball yeah
there's some guys are complete jerks and
things have happened and some people
have broken the law and the rest but
there's a minut minority yeah and and I
do want to say this too that it you know
it may turn out that Ezekiel Elliott is
isn't somebody who should be in the
crosshairs right now although there were
things other than what he is getting a
six game suspension for but let's put
that aside what let's talk about the
Yankees and the Red Sox here with what's
going on with Major League Baseball how
how did how does this land on Manfred's
desk and what does he think about it
Peter why dude a lot yesterday he was in
Boston but he'd already gotten early
July complaints from the Red Sox about
the Yankees and the use of the es
cameras then he got the then they got
the a lot of the charges against the Red
Sox Yankees made that was July 18th when
they made that and then it cropped up
for both sides in the last week I mean
listen there are very few people ever
been in journalism there's better than
Michael but I mean and so I'm a huge fan
Cashman believe it is integrity at all
the rest I'll say this I just awful lot
we don't know like a good friend of mine
in the Red Sox organization Peter there
was no Apple watch I mean so we don't
know everything what we do know and the
Red Sox admitted was that there was
somebody in the universe let's start out
with a device and electrons and let that
is illegal but let's I it's a book of
the rules now this obviously this is you
know some of these awards should be like
Cardinals in the ad no no no no because
Korea went to jail and is still in jail
he book will be booked a little law by
hacking into the Astro system that's net
I mean a totally different thing you're
not gonna even if it were an Apple watch
you know you're not going to you're not
going to prison over stealing signs but
I think it's still what we don't know I
mean I think that because what's
available to us is increasingly
complicated in and really interesting
and there can be useful wild things and
not just Apple watches that I think the
Commissioner has to come down hard
listen you guys violating the wall not
gonna lose craft choices and I gonna
lose games but at the same time yeah
well I think they'll be there will be
punishment and I think it'll be they'll
come down heavy now if what the wet
socks are charging which yeah I found a
little hard to believe because of cash
women because of Joe Girardi I mean I
but if it's indeed what they're saying
is true he may come down the Yankees to
but you can see I mean yeah I've been
through so many school board in Chicago
at the old Comiskey Park the Minnesota
Twins would be having the monitors right
around the corner from where the manager
suddenly died out what's I moved into
the Metrodome the metro rail ride I
remember this I mean I once time once
had a pitching coach Saint me watch
video with live sound because the the
the microphones on the screen so you
could hear a lot of things you normally
wouldn't your honor but I watch it for
an hour and five minutes about you know
the Indians tapping their bats and this
would tell hitters and if you follow the
story this morning about the guy in the
video room
then sending information to the
assistant trainer with a watch and then
a player passing on that information to
a runner at second base how much time
it's about three or four seconds between
when the pitcher gets up gets a sign
when he goes into his wind-up that's not
practical yeah it does sound it does
stretch credulity there Peter
okay would be would be
location location you can also tell you
if if it's down the way in certain
situations you know a pretty guy the
idea is a breaking ball or a fastball
that's fine but so but let me let me
tell you that Peter Gammons in the MLB
network here so let's let's just take
this piecemeal you're saying that you've
spoken to someone in the Red Sox
organization that says flat-out there
was no Apple watch involved in this
situation right but there is something
else okay so okay so let's just a lot of
fun I could go buy one today well what
can I do it change some grades from like
50 years ago maybe you never know what
they might be an app for that too Peter
so but but and then and then
extrapolating us a little bit further
though okay is that is that this may
just at some point just be the
Commissioner saying cheating is cheating
and they just used a device that they
shouldn't have and there's really no
there's really no there there and might
just slap on the wrist or do nothing
even playing heavily and I think
there'll be some creative ways I thought
a couple of years ago and I did think
that the Commission was unfair to Eddie
Romero Rosie international Scotland I
thought I saw some really smart one of
the best young executives in game they
were doing things where they would in
Venezuela where guys young players
coming up with them they hope to sign
would be training with certain guys if
the trainer could get three guys
$300,000 apiece rather than one guy
getting 500 one guy getting 300 and one
guy getting 100 they were packing over
there was bubble work together and that
is illegal you know that this at the
time they do you know probably 15 to 20
teams do it but and he really came down
and took away their right to sign
international players for two years and
so you know it's not that well I thought
they'd say I thought they came now too
hard because there were so many to you
but that's okay I mean it's yeah you get
punished well in terms of what other
teams do Peter now the fact that this
may be born out of what a lot of teams
do with video replay systems put in the
put in in recent years because teams
before they are a challenge have
somebody look at the replay themselves
right before figuring out and with the
NFL the difference is with the NFL and
Major League Baseball is that there
isn't a camera in the NFL on the person
sending in the signs because they can
send in the signs through a helmet do
you think baseball will either through
this with this thing either a remove or
change the video replay system to just
remove this video out although you could
still get it I guess watching games as
the Red Sox are accusing the Yankees of
using their camera or be doing what the
NFL does removing the old school catcher
flashing signs to the pitcher and that
somebody from the dugout can call the
game with a piece in the catcher's ear
and the pitchers here Peter
there is the games are telling them they
probably they have an in-house camera so
much of advanced work in terms of
scouting comes from the video I mean
they have it a lot of teams still have
advanced Scouts but they break it down
whether they have old teams of people
who break down other teams and it's a
very complicated process they probably
have four different cam
shots but I mean if you're watching no
matter what you're watching what network
it's yes or Nessun or well you're
fortunate enough to watch the Dodger
Network you know you'll be able to see
basically what the catchers up putting
down and you can see location so and
that's what's useful it's useful Scouty
and that's like I've change so they have
to figure out how they go about a little
bit better in but I mean it also can be
you know what I did several pieces for
us being over the years about you know
pitchers tipping pitchers and hitters
and what amazed me is how many hitters
didn't want to know I'm a really time
yeah it's it's funny I mean the master
of all this is one of the smartest
people I've ever known in sports but so
I did a thing when with a lot of Palm
Springs and did a thing sat down at a
hotel room with Tony Gwynn and Greg
Maddux and we showed we showed them I
think those 20 of their 20 at-bats with
him opposing one another and the two of
them talking about what they were
thinking it was a this great it's great
fun to do and hopefully it was good good
television but it was fascinating but at
one point late in the in them while
while doing this Malick's wrote wait a
minute I can't remember where those
Ricky Gutierrez somebody was on second
but he was leaning he was tipping he's
trying to give Gwynn an idea of where
Maddux was going where where Lopez's
know who's catching him then
well whatever we'll set it up and you
know so max the overtone oh no I
wouldn't do that you know bah blah so I
remember afterwards I've stayed around
for a while with Greg he said that's
just to put it in his mind and then as I
found out later I did a piece
Spring Training I'm Alex and his khakis
and he gave the science catchers didn't
get inside he would let the cat your is
Eddie Perez catch us yeah Eddie Perez he
wanted a dress and get him back the ball
in two seconds and so a Perez get the
ball full of it and how Maddux caught
the ball was telling Eddie Perez what
pitch he was gonna throw the next pitch
I love it he came to sign himself and
then funny thing was a but part of it
was that Maddux always it's just an
Eddie Perez just set up in the middle of
the plate and then because once in a
while
Greg would change his mind in the middle
of this wind up the hill and Matt had
made an adjustment with his feet or his
hands or whatever nice awesome and so
the whole thing was just and he Maddux
also did a big one spring training I was
doing thing about tipping pitches he
went out showed our cameramen where to
be he would show how you could see the
ball and the next inning would show how
he protected it so you couldn't see it
so nobody it's a no third-base coach
nobody could could could tip the hearing
it was fascinating but you know Maddux
is giving Tony Gwynn grief about getting
kitchens tip to him when you couldn't
have tipped batiks as pictures anyway
I'd love it Peter you're the best thanks
for calling in Thank You bud Peter
Gammons at peak ammo Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you liked that video be sure to
download our app and I'll be sure to
help the NFL figure out what it catches